we all know how leon trotsky stint in
exile ended and if you don't know it was
ended in 1940 when a chap called Ramon
Mercado introduced an ice axe to the
back of Trotsky skull his exile had
begun after he was unceremoniously
punted out of the Soviet Union in 1929
by none other than Joseph Stalin but
something not often asked about is what
did he do whilst in exile immediately
after he was given his marching orders
Trotsky was sent to Turkey where he
lived for about four years this was
because Turkey's president Mustafa Kemal
atatürk was concerned that the Communist
revolutionary was going to do well
revolutionary communist things as such
all of his letters were intercepted and
he was kept under consistent supervision
by the police in 1933 President
edouard de la da of France invited
Trotsky to live there which Trotsky
gladly accepted - la da though after
offering asylum to Trotsky had a
realization this guy is a communist
revolutionary he's probably going to do
revolutionary communist things when he
gets here as such he decided that
Trotsky would remain here since he felt
that putting Trotsky in Paris around
about all of those other communists
would be a recipe for disaster
now this didn't stop Trotsky from
writing and publishing numerous
anti-government articles and also French
communists could leave Paris and go to
Trotsky which they did as such the
French kept him under constant police
supervision and monitored any in all of
his communications and in case you're
wondering this will be a running theme
also trotsky's residents complicated
Frances foreign policy in 1933 a certain
Adolf Hitler took power in Germany and
Trotsky felt that this was the fault of
Stalin for not ordering the German
communists to form a united front
against him he also felt the Moscow
wasn't preparing for conflict with
Germany which he saw as a dereliction of
duty which Starlin was in case you're
wondering not a fan of this was
important to France because it's prime
minister who changed every five minutes
at this point was concerned about German
rearmament and so sought to build an
alliance with the USSR the USSR wanted
Trotsky gone but France opted to stand
up for their principles and just kidding
they kicked him out in 1935 well they
tried to it took a while because
everywhere else refused to have him the
country that finally accepted him was
Norway and upon his arrival they
probably put him under police
surveillance because they were concerned
he'd incite revolution to be fair to
Trotsky though he wasn't inciting it in
Norway but instead spent many months
writing text calling for French workers
to strike and if necessary overthrow the
government Norway was under a lot of
pressure by Stalin to get rid of trot
okey and they made him a deal stop
inciting revolution in criticizing
Stalin and you can stay Trotsky said no
because what else was he gonna do with
his time and so was shipped to Mexico in
1937 the reason why the pressure was so
fierce was that back in the USSR the
Great Purge was beginning to really ramp
up and those who were seen his opponents
to the state were branded trotskyists
and Norway didn't want to be the one
harboring him in case things got well
heated when Trotsky got to Mexico he was
given a warm welcome and given a place
to live in Mexico City during his time
in Mexico Trotsky continued writing
anti-stalinist works and also started to
liaise with prominent American
communists in fact Trotsky was invited
to the USA to testify to Congress about
what the purpose of the American
Communist Party was however when he
declared he was going to use it as a
platform to denounce Stalin and to
everyone's surprise call for the
overthrow of American capitalism his
invitation was revoked he also formed
the Fourth International which opposed
the Third International the
International Group which was comprised
of many communist parties including that
of the USSR Trotsky was at this point
openly calling for the deposition of
Stalin and for all over communists to
break ties with the USSR and as the
prospect of war seemed to get closer
Starlin took a lesson from history best
not to let an exiled revolutionary
returned during a war and overthrow the
government and so he put an end to
trotsky's exile by having him
assassinated I hope you enjoyed this
episode and thank you for watching with
the special thanks to my patreon
supporters James Bissonnette Colin
Castleman Danny Maloney Marvin Castle
Rob Waterhouse John BJ's Mo Aaron the
white Michael Reynolds James Castaneda
Gustav Swann Marcus Ozma Jordan Longley
James Castaneda Gustav Swann Marcus Ozma
Jordan Longley Gareth Turner mr. show
Rashid Ali spinning three plates filled
- oink oink David Silverman is he
Winston Cawood Maggie packs Kowski Lexi
Schwinn Spencer Lightfoot Kelly
moneymaker
Robert Wetzel Skye Chappelle and Anthony
Beckett